selim fourniret vous l'avez vu et vous
l'avez entendu dans le documentaire
le psychiatre daniel zagury déclare que
fourniret est l'un des pires cas dont il
a eu connaissance
mais ce pire cas c'est quand même votre
père évidemment on se demande quel genre
d'enfance vous avez eue auprès de cet
homme
j'ai eu une enfance je connaissais pas
cet univers tant que kiné c'était en
france tout le monde
ce n'est pas un père aimant c'est pas un
père qui vient faire des câlins qui
vient qui vient aider sa mère
autoritaire pas violent mais voilà c'est
seulement quand été arrêté peu après que
j'ai appris la vérité quand vous dites
ce n'est pas c'était un père autoritaire
pas violent il n'y avait rien dans son
comportement qui à vos yeux d'enfant
paraissait anormal non je voyais mes
amis qui jouent avec leurs parents moi
il n'y avait pas ça mon père travailler
sur la maison qui était un chantier et
travailler revenez vois rien je pouvais
pas supposer qu'elle ait autre chose et
quand est ce que vous avez connu l'autre
face de votre père quand est ce que la
vérité criminel vous êtes apparu dans
quelles circonstances
c'était pas son arrestation un comédien
monique n'a pas voulu me dire exactement
ce qui se passait quand michel est à
l'onu d'être votre mère donc voila quand
michel a été a été arrêté j'étais en
voyage scolaire
s'ils rentrent le soir et monique est
venu me chercher et m'a dit ton père
n'est pas là voilà quand on est rentré à
la maison il y avait des véhicules de
police devant la maison
vous l'avez me dire c'est après en
allumant la télé ouvrir les infos que
j'ai appris ce qui s'était passé vous
aviez quel âge j'avais 14 ans
et qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête
d'un enfant qui est confrontée à une
nouvelle hausse inattendue aussi
tragique aussi surprenantes comme en ont
réussi à simuler sa à cet âge là qu'est
ce qui se passe dans votre tête
c'est déroutant ce je pense pas ce qui
se passe en comprend pas vraiment au
début quand on rentre on va toutes les
voitures de police oh je sais qu'on perd
avec des armes à la maison je dis
peut-être que c'est un gangster un
criminel qui a été un braquage ou je ne
sais pas et donc on pourrait presque
considérer comme un héros et après quand
on apprend ce qui s'est vraiment passé
c'est sa chute libre on se dit c'est ça
mon père n'en revient pas mais comme
vous comment vous l'avez appris
exactement les détails de ce qui lui
était voilà pourquoi il était emprisonné
au début c'était seulement pour
l'enlèvement d'une jeune fille
assassinée
j'ai réussi à s'échapper et c'est
seulement après les aveux de monique que
j'ai vraiment pris conscience de la
gravité de directs savaient mais dans
vos souvenirs hisser mais monique et
michel fourniret
quand vous étiez petit il faisait des
bisous il était tendre vous aviez
l'impression d'un couple uni non comme
avec moi était pas avec eux n'étaient
pas effectués avec elle était beaucoup
de disputes
j'aimais de violence physique mais pas
il s'en est pas éventré l'amour et
quelles étaient les conversations à
table ou dans la famille comme ça dans
les dents le quotidien s'est il parle et
de quoi vos parents dans mes souvenirs
c'était des conversations classique
normale sur la journée sauf qu'ils
avaient fait le travail sur
sommer notes à l'école sur sur les amis
qu'ils voyaient qui venaient à la maison
quand rencontrer d'après les auditions
que j'ai il reste un an
j'applique que des fois et parler de
désagréments qu'il avait fait mais je
n'avais pas conscience de ça peut-être
que j'écoutais pas nous le dire en votre
présence si le temps d une seconde on a
un problème de micro ou alors on va
essayer d'arranger ça micro en main
en attendant je profite pour poser une
question assez nîmes quand les justes
qui termina d'accord je vous dis juste
qu'on l'a pas entendu ce courrier
reprend voilà oui je disais il faut
savoir que en privé selon ses dires
michel fourniret c'était quelqu'un qui
était tout à fait normal qu'ils adorent
et pousser la chansonnette à la maison
il adorait jouer au piano
monique olivier elle adorait regarder
s'abêtir de vendée des séries télé comme
julie lescaut l'adoré ça en fait c'est
l'hymne va faire la connaissance du
véritable michel fourniret le 16 janvier
à l'occasion d'une visite en ma présence
c'est la première fois en fait si vous
voulez qu'il va véritablement rencontré
le l'ogre des ardennes michel fourniret
connu comme étant un pédophile et
assassin notoire avance à selim comme il
le dit souvent
il faisait face à une sorte d'acteur
quelqu'un qui joue et le régional et
pourquoi en votre présence la première
la première rencontre si vous voulez moi
je rencontre c'est l'hymne à la base
c'était pour c'était pour les besoins
d'une interview que j'avais vendu au
journal au magazine vsd
voilà une interview tout à fait
classique moi je connaissais pas du tout
la sphère fournir et à la base il
découvre une des heroes diffusion de
faites entrer l'accusé j'étais chez ma
grand mère et là j'entends parler de
gang des postiches qu'il aurait volé
butin du gang pour s'acheter un château
et voilà ça ressemble en rien aux autres
affaires donc à partir de ce moment là
moi j'apprends à la fin du documentaire
que selim a depuis refait sa vie dans le
sud de la france sous une nouvelle
identité
étant originaire de nice je me suis dit
tiens j'ai il habite chez moi j'ai une
carte à jouer
donc là j'ai entamé des recherches je
les retrouvais fatalité qui s'avérait
que c'était vraiment lui derrière le
compte que j'avais trouvé sur les
réseaux sociaux
il a mis un an de répondre et à partir
de là je les rencontrer
le lendemain notre rencontre si ça qui
était marquant céline reçoit une lettre
de michel fourniret dont ils n'avaient
plus de nouvelles depuis dix ans il m'a
soupçonné d'être dans coût des mèches
avec michel fourniret
c'est absolument pas le cas et c'était
troublant près moi j'ai vu la marque du
destin je me suis dit tiens et si au
delà de l'interview qu'on a fait
paraître dans vsd
ça ne dirais pas qu'on continue de lui
écrire pour essayer de rentrer dans sa
tête petit à petit sans qu'ils s'en
rendent compte pour moi je décide à ce
moment là d'être sous couverture céline
lui valut écrire et nous non sans nous
avons fignolé des lettres ça va durer
trois quatre ans quand même on va
s'immiscer dans son cerveau et ça va
aboutir jusqu'au moment où moi je lui
propose carrément ça ne dirais pas qu'on
franchisse le pas qu'on ait carrément en
prison on a fait une demande de permis
de visite qui a été validé avec une
simplicité confondante on m'a même pas
demandé si j'étais journaliste quoi j'ai
même pas eu la peine de de m'expliquer
quoi j'étais les inscrits en tant que
c'est un peu le soutien moral et ça a
été ça a été facile
donc c'est vraiment le 16 janvier 2016
que selim pas vraiment rencontré michel
fourniret pour l'année on va y revenir
mais je voudrais juste revenir un peu en
arrière parce qu'il se trouve que votre
mère monique olivier est arrêté assez
peu de temps après c'est l'année
suivante je crois c'est 2003 par michel
fourniret et 2004 pour votre mère donc
là c'est on se pose les mêmes questions
au carré qu'est ce qui peut bien se
passer dans la tête de quelqu'un qui est
encore très jeune quand ses deux parents
surtout pour les crimes atroces qui leur
sont reprochés se retrouve en prison
tous les deux d'abord un peu une
question très prisé qui s'occupe de vous
à ce moment là alors après l'arrestation
de michel monique et moi on a déménagé
quelques rappels et monique était
souvent convoqué au commissariat pour
des auditions et un an après comme
d'habitude
enfin comme souvent est parti pour une
audition et les parents c'est que la
première nuit elle est pas rentré
lendemain j'ai entendu rien j'ai pas de
nouvelles j'ai personnes à contacter on
n'a pas donné de nouvelles
troisième jour et c'est une seule vous
étiez absolument seul oui c'est dur de
surprise n'est même pas appeler rien non
non je sais pas ce qui se passait mais
quels jeux vous aviez à ce moment là
j'avais 15 ans il me semble ah oui dès
15 ans donc le tri corps étaient pleins
heureusement et j'attendais attendez je
sais pas ce qui se passait je suis dit
on va rentrer bientôt le final c'est mon
oncle paternel il me semble qu est venue
me récupérer et quels souvenirs
j'aurais vite élevées parti après
justement enfin vous avez poursuivi a
plus que chez mon oncle non peut être
après c'est mon demi-frère de l'office
de ma mère d'accord qu'il veut chercher
excusez moi il est humain eric mais vous
n'avez pas eu peur de votre oncle parce
que vous auriez pu ne plus avoir de
repères avec votre famille en pensant
que tout le monde pouvait avoir une
pathologie non c'est pas ça n'est pas
content c'est pas quelque chose qui est
dans les gènes donc je sais que mon
grand-père était pas comme ça le ferait
pas comme ça pour qu'elle s'ajuste à
michel qui était traquée céline sait que
s'il il faudra juste au niveau lui dire
un point important que moi tu m'avais
dit c'est que cette année là durant
laquelle michel n'est plus là ça a été
la plus belle année de sa vie ses
lectures et auprès de ta mère tu sentais
que vous étiez libérer d'un point si ce
que tu m'avais dit oui quand on est à la
maison c'était oppressant et toujours
l'attention s'est jamais égalé
et sénart et était très autoritaire très
colérique camp était pas là c'était bien
non mais ça a été de courte durée cette
parenthèse surtout ici surtout pas c'est
un fait important c'est ce que je
dévoile dans le livre c'était une
révélation qui m'a faite sur le tard
j'étais à deux doigts de pas le maître
mais faut savoir que quand son père est
arrêté
la première réaction de monique c'est de
se précipiter avec selim dans les bois à
vol sort pour planquer les reste du
butin du gang des postiches
elle admet la force et selim à le faire
de ses propres mains en plein milieu des
bois dont keith explique aussi pourquoi
céline ce soir il est gris mais c'est
parce que sa sécurité et vittavi
évidemment mise en danger est très
billet dès qu'un client va revenir sur
le chercher à faire du gang des
postiches et une affaire dans la ferme
et 10 milliards il ensuite on veut
revenir à ça car depuis le début c'est
l'hymne quand vous répondez aux
questions vous dit monique et michel
vous les appeler par leur prénom
vous dites pas mon père ou ma mère est
ce que c'est parce que vous n'arrivez
pas à le dire vous ne voulez pas le dire
vous ne pouvez plus le dire est ce que
ce sont des étrangers pour vous
aujourd'hui que vous appeler par leur
prénom parce que vous ne vous
reconnaissez pas dans cette histoire et
vous êtes tellement loin de tout ça que
pour vous c'est monique et michel est
plus mon père et ma mère conte comment
vous expliquez que vous voulez prennent
au mieux sans les intitulés comme vos
parents ou quoi chez les mx aujourd'hui
on est sans arrêt saisissons c'est
qu'ils n'ont pas considéré comme leur
fils six ans qu'ils ont fait ces choses
c'est qu'ils respectent pas la famille
s'il avait du respect pour moi de
l'amour pour leur fils
il n'a pas fait ça tant qu'à partir de
là pourquoi je devrais considère comme
au mois et son nom et vous voulez dire
que en plus d'être des criminels ils
nous ont trahis en quelque sorte mais au
moins jouer un rôle pour moi c'était
papa maman ouais en temps quand s'en
sort dont
et bien ensemble c'était bien et après
j'ai appris qu'elle mentait qui joue un
jeu où ils ont été jusqu'à se servir de
ces lignes comme appât pour piéger de
janeiro sait aujourd'hui où les
considérait plus comme vos parents et
vous voyez le reste de la famille les
oncles les tantes fait les frères et
soeurs des frères et soeurs les voiliers
ou quoi non pas celle qu'ils ont couvé
le contact parce que je suis le fils 2
mais non pas ça mais vous avez un
demi-frère de les citer tout à l'heure
et et une soeur aussi c'est ça oui mais
de mes frères et mes soeurs j'ai pas
encore d'accord et tout ce qui est en
attente cousin cousine de michel
fourniret avait de l'humour oui
apparemment oui
ah oui on n'avait qu'un navet c'était
quelqu'un de normal il était autoritaire
qui se discute avec beaucoup de monde à
sainte christine tous les voisins
détester mais c'était quelqu'un norman
gobbi le dire aujourd'hui vous faites
quoi dans la vie ces lignes vous pouvez
le dire ou pas quelle est votre activité
c'est intéressant d'accord vous dites
que vous avez résisté à l'appel du
suicide
contrairement à votre demi soeur oui
c'est plus de la lâcheté j'ai jamais osé
franchir le cap et après mon frère qui
m'a accueilli qui est devenu mon tuteur
légal alors qu'il n'avait que 21 ans
moi j'en avais 15 c'est lui qui m'a
jamais attiré par l'eau qui m'a poussé à
voir au delà a pas pensé à ça j'ai dit
pourquoi vous êtes converti à l'islam
c'est intéressant moi je voudrais qu'on
revienne aux retrouvailles avec le père
comment ça se passe et retrouvailles
avec le père il ya un avant et un après
c'est plus du tout l'homme que vous
connaissez vous ne serez pas reconnu
qu'il avait à bord se sont même pas
reconnue c'est moi qui lui ai expliqué
qu'ils étaient qu'il allait demander à
une gardienne à ce point d'avoir michel
fourniret est juste sous vos yeux moi
j'ai reconnu direct parce que j'avais
l'impression de voir une célébrité quand
je connais son visage dans les médias
les père et fils sont pas reconnus pour
michel fourniret lui s'est dit mais tu
es resté un petit garçon qui l'avait vu
au parloir dizaine d'années j'anime une
fois que vous êtes reconnu qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire à un père dans ces
circonstances qu'est ce qu'un père peut
dire un fils dans ces circonstances
quand j'ai vu c'était
et qu'on peut voir les autres photos n'a
pas de barbe est parce que l on peut
dire qu'elle commence comme la
maintenant et qu'on avait en maison
d'arrêt il était tout petit les cheveux
longs la salle mardi
d'où la faible on dit un petit papy on
est de se dire qu'est ce qui fait en
prison
et quand on apprend que c'est michel
fournier vous parlez de quoi ce moment
là qu'elle est comment une discussion
peut s'engager d'abord dans ce cadre
après tout ce qui s'est passé vous ce
que vous avez sur le coeur ce que vous
savez sur sur votre père je passe voilà
je n'arrive pas à imaginer ce que vous
pouvez vous dire je suis pas déçu pas là
bas pour voir papa et ce l'est pour voir
michel fourniret a comme objectif que
vous avez un mac os 10 5 à partir de là
on savait de quoi il parlait voilà où
était d'un pc ça que nous avions lui
s'est mis sa chaise pour enfants c'est
toi qui l'as ça c'est super important
parce qu'il faut savoir que quand on
rentre dans le box du parloir
selim fournir et se dirige vers le totem
de chaises qui est dressé devant nous et
c'est lui qui distribue les chaises et
il distribuait ce jour-là à michel
fourniret une chaise pour enfants à ras
du sol et michel fourniret il le fait
asseoir comme un toutou il s'exécute
s'exécute fils à ses lubies assieds-toi
ici et il s'assoira le sol et nous on
était un peu comme deux juges face à lui
sur la sélune ce jour là à lui a donné
la leçon de sa vie mais michel fourniret
ils étaient sidérés sur la ils
n'arrêtaient pas de pousser des
onomatopées selim sétois et il croyait
en fait que c'était encore la justice et
de la juge fabi mme quéré c'est ce qu'il
dit d'emblée qui venait lui parler de la
disparition d'estelle mouzin s'est il
commence lui-même direct sur la ferme
houssin parce que là moi pour la
première fois que je prends la parole ce
que c'est vrai que cette fois là céline
vraiment il re devenu acteur de sa
propre histoire moi je re je fais un peu
en arrière et je lui dis mais attention
il ya vous n'êtes pas milliers en examen
que pour la disparition de la petite
estelle mouzin il ya aussi la sphère pas
riche mais c'est la première fois qu'il
se tourne vers moi michel fourniret qui
murat droit dans les yeux qui me dira
non mais c'est assez différent là là là
là c'était moi mais pour rester de nous
un sécher n'ai rien à voir dans cette
histoire je suis droit dans mes bottes
je n'ai absolument rien à bord il a juré
mordicus qu'il n'avait absolument rien à
voir avec mouzin mais que paris s'était
lui donc
il aurait menti 10 secondes avant
d'avouer un meurtre qu'il n'avait encore
jamais fait aux enquêteurs
d'ailleurs ça nous a valu les foudres
des enquêteurs tout est bien c'est moi
qui ai annoncé la nouvelle d'ailleurs à
monsieur rogers pas riche
le père de john acquis et est donc
décédé en 1990 et qui avait carrément
lancé une pétition en ligne pour
dénoncer l'engourdissement de la justice
française donc il a fallu qu'on aille
rendent visite à fournir et pour enfin
de le faire parler des aveux qu'il a
ensuite réitéré auprès des enquêteurs
donc il admet la responsabilité dans un
meurtre il dit qu'il n'a rien à voir
avec celui d'estelle mouzin et partant
monique olivier affirme que c'est bien
lui le meurtrier
c'est une des affaires qui bouleverse le
plus la france qui passionne le plus la
france c'est une disparition
inexplicable
on a appris ce soir c'est que d'une
source donc je le donne sous réserve qu
ont abandonné les recherches dans
l'ancien château de michel fourniret
parce qu'on n'a pas retrouvé de corps et
qu'a priori les recherches ne ne
reprendront pas mais comment
expliquez-vous qu'il nie
sur ce point alors qu'il a nommé la
culpabilité sur un autre et que j'allais
dire au point où il en est il est plus
un meurtre près d'un il ya déjà la
conscience extrêmement chargé le casier
judiciaire extrêmement chargé comment
expliquez vous qu'il n'y pour estelle
mouzin et est beaucoup de choses encore
c'est sûr il ya apparemment blanche où
il aurait commis personnellement j'y
crois pas il pourrait être dire tout ce
qu'il a tout ce qu'il a fait s'il fait
ça après c'est un nombre on parlera plus
de lui alors que là et peut sortir de
temps en temps pour soigner les
enquêteurs pour nous montrer un jardin
un parc une forêt et prendrait démarche
un peu et quand il sera mort qu'on
trouvera un accord on pourra dire ses
côtés du chef on irait aux paras
toujours de lui il vous pensez qu'ils
poussent le calcul jusqu'à ce point là
ouais ça allait se retrouver ou la
jouissance pas le calcul la jouissance
mais qui est là pour rester pour jouir
savoir michel fourniret c'est un joueur
d'échecs nous quand on le rencontre en
prison il nous dit que les inspecteurs
sont mauvais et qu'ils sont incapables
de poser les bonnes questions que se
sont des abrutis
mais si on regarde pas ses mots donc il
considère qu on a qu'à lui poser les
bonnes questions pour le pousser à
répondre et que c'est la police qui fait
un mauvais travail selon lui quand j'ai
une question vous merci beaucoup de nous
confier votre témoignage passe quelque
chose de très intime et très personnelle
et qui en même temps
nous concerne tous parce qu'on a tous
été suivie cette actualité depuis depuis
chez nous merci de me confier cette
parole vous décrivez de manière
extrêmement chirurgicale est assez
froide quelque chose qui est très
personnel vous nous avez dit à l'instant
que vous aviez renoncer à appeler vos
parents pères et mères ou papa et maman
moi ce qui m'intrigue c'est que vous
avez reçu votre père que vous n'allez
pas revu depuis quasiment votre enfance
vous leur envoyez avec un projet
extrêmement précis qui est de faire ce
livre qu'est ce que vous ressentez c'est
à dire comment vous arrivez à dissocier
l'enfant trail de la personne qui a un
projet quasi journalistique je trouve
que c'est vraiment à la fois extrêmement
fort courageux mais en même temps
j'imagine que vous avez dû être bousculé
de ressentir autant de choses en même
temps oui c'était c'était émouvant mais
d'un autre côté michel et monique se
sont rencontrés en passera contrat et
devait tuer l'ex mari de monique et il
s'avère que cet ex mari est devenu mon
nouveau père auquel le centre puis son
fils est devenu un tuteur légal
alors qu'il devait mourir donc j'avais
comme un nouveau père on peut dire c'est
lui qui s'occupait de moi c'est qu'ils
marché du revêtement
c'est qu'il m'a donné à manger et après
j'ai rencontré michel en prison qui lui
ne s'était pas occupé de moi qui au
cours de son incarcération n'a pas écrit
n'a pas cherché à prendre de mes
nouvelles
donc est ce qu'un père ferait ça non et
votre vie votre maire estime wang wei et
votre mère vous avez eu aucun contact
avec elle durant toute cette période
au début j'ai prenez contact avec l oms
écrivait régulièrement
oui d'accord et après la lumière était
fait sur le fait qu était pas victimes
mes complices au même titre que les
chaînes peut-être pire que je me suis
dit que ça vient pas des gens comme ça
céline quand vous avez connu enquête
vous avez entendu parler de date
est-ce que vous avez essayé parfois
d'imaginer ce que vous faisiez vous à
telle ou telle date et de le relier à un
souvenir en vous demandant mais ce jour
là je vois en gros ce que je faisais
extra décide à voir si rétrospectivement
vous auriez pu deviner avoir des
éléments est ce que vous avez cherché à
faire ça même inconsciemment je veux
dire ouais j'ai essayé et alors il ya ça
marche jamais vous ne pouvez jamais
deviner quoi que ce soit y aille a aucun
élément qui aurait pu vous permettre
d'avoir un peu un petit soupçon
nantes et amassé à la maison c'est vrai
qu'il y avait beaucoup d'argent c'était
lors des postiches quoi ça tu te
rappelles qui avaient énormément de fric
cash et moi je parle plutôt d une
étrange nathan et moi je voudrais juste
qu'on n'explique pas ce qu'il ya
peut-être des gens qui sont pas
familiers avec cette affaire ce qui
s'est passé parce que au milieu de tous
ces crimes c'est presque quelque chose
de rocambolesques et romane et voilà
donc le gang des postiches on explique
c'est un gang qui sévissait à paris dans
les années 80 c'était l'inconnu andré
bellaïche témoin j'ai tout connu un vrai
qu'il m'a collé une réputation mais
c'est pas le lieu de la raconter ici
simplement on dit que donc et vous avez
l'air de le confirmer que michel
fourniret auraient fait main basse sur
le magot assure hugues langue des
postiches qui utilisent encore le
conditionnel à ce sujet la langue nous
l'avons en prison il nous a d'ailleurs
exprimé son seul regret la ftq hainaut
ce qui s'est passé oui en fait si vous
voulez l'époque où michel fourniret déjà
accusé d'attouchements sur mineur donc
il est en séjour d'un fleury mérogis
et là il fait la connaissance d'un
certain jean pierre hellegouarch qui est
un des proches des postiches qui se fait
appeler le breton qui d'ailleurs le
parrain de selim pour vous dire un peu
et donc du coup cet homme va lui c'est
prendre d'amitié pour michel fourniret
et lui indiquer où est enterrée lors
dans le projet que michel fourniret une
fois libre prennent contact avec farida
hammiche qui l'accompagnent de du breton
pour aller déterrer cet or est le
partager avec farida
sauf qu'une fois sur place quand il sort
il tue farida avec une grands coups de
baïonnette et ils empochent l'or et avec
cet argent là il va s'acheter le château
moulinsart quoi qui est le domaine du
saux tout temps qu'elle selim lui-même a
vécu mais dont il n'a pas le souvenir
quoi et en prison c'est michel fourniret
nous exprimer un seul regret c'est ça
qui est terrible dans notre rencontre
avec lui c'est que il ne regrette pas
d'avoir ôté la vie à deux innocentes
créatures
il regrette d'avoir tué farida par
respect pour
pour ce braqueur qui est jean pierre
hellegouarch le par anne sélime et il me
dit même à un moment donné en bradant
droit dans les yeux il dit il est
certain que si j'avais andré bellaïche
en face de moi maintenant je passerai un
sale quart d'heure
mais je n'aurais peut-être pas dû je
regrette parce que c'est vraiment un
chic type jean pierre hellegouarch c'est
son seul regret dans tous toute cette
affaire
alors j'ai une question pour selim henri
bernard aller ce soir était
qui te regardent qui vous regarde michel
fourniret depuis sa cellule où sa
chambre d'hôpital puisque je crois qu'il
est malade qu'est ce que vous avez à lui
dire
alors dans sa cellule et n'a pas atterri
là justin post radio et écrit beaucoup
par sa chambre d'hôpital je pense que ça
va être pareil et j'ai rien à lui dire
juste pas dit et quoi vous avez des
nouvelles
vous savez qu'il ya pas la télé et ses
exploits c'est j'ai reçu un rapport de
la maison d'arrêt dix ans qu'ils
n'avaient pas la télévision
donc nous sommes en prison si vous quand
vous êtes allé le voir en prison c'était
pour vous pour votre construction parce
que vous aviez besoin pour devenir
l'homme au couvent est devenu où c'était
parce que vous vouliez effectivement
l'entendre est lui élu lui lui et lui
exhorté un peu des choses des vérités
c'est pourquoi vous y est allé en fait
pourquoi vous avez fait ce livre
pourquoi cette démarche vous auriez pu
l'ignorer dire moi je veux plus jamais
le voir je le banni de ma vie donc
pourquoi vous avez souhaité y aller ces
cités s'ils ne raisons personnelles pour
votre l'instruction est ce que c'est
vous qui l'avez forcément à n'ont pas
forcé non non moi je lui ai quantité
d'accord dit est d'accord pour jouer le
jeu ils avaient vraiment ici on se dit
lui rendre les coups à son père en fait
mon premier nous avait pas échappé seul
hymne rencontré au lit et écrire ce
livre c'est un exutoire pour moi j'ai pu
répondre à des questions que l'on n'est
pas posée par et de choses que j'ai
jamais parlé je peux pas paraître ça mes
amis ma famille on essaye d'éviter le
sujet donc c'est un exutoire
d'après le projet d'aller rencontrer
michel c'était quelque sorte une
vengeance il faut le voir le voir
enfermé une vengeance oui voilà
vengeance la reconstruction par la bande
lancions pellet poser c'est fort comme
expression une reconstruction par la
vengeance est ce que c'est vraiment
votre état d'esprit
oui le voir leur a détruit la fait
pleurer michel fourniret en prison l'a
laissé en miettes michel fourniret
il est parti clopin clopant en pleurant
il vous a demandé pardon michel
fourniret ou pas mais exprime des
regrets
non non comment vous l'avez fait pleurer
en parlant de son fils qui est mort il
ya quelques années
donc il est fasciné par la mort son fils
comme était vivant et ne s'en occupait
pas était ça ne coûtait pas lui chercher
à être son exemple être être reconnu par
son père c'est une fois que ce fils est
mort que michel s'intéresse à lui quand
il a reçu l'appel de prince et la mort
de son fils était détruit il a pleuré et
donc ce jour là la maison d'arrêt et la
voulais jouer le le surhomme qui n'a pas
senti mans qui oublient sur lui moi je
lui rappelais quand son fils est mort
qu'il règlerait elle a commencé à à
pleurer et à dire oui c'est vrai nicolas
selim donc c'est la première fois que
vous accepté une invitation à la
télévision quand on vous pose des
questions que vous revivez certains
événements vous éprouvez un sentiment de
soulagement ça vous fait mal en même
temps qu'est ce qu'elle est votre état
d'esprit pendant que vous répondez à
tout était encore en thérapie ou à te
c'est terminé pour bouffer à faire dans
un stade
j'ai accepté cette invitation pouvoir
répondre à des questions qui n'ont pas
être posée les sujets qui ont été
écartés par les autres médias
occultée par la justice alors ok merci
aux héros juste une chose par rapport à
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
faut savoir que quand on laisse michel
fourniret en miettes en train de pleurer
et de boîtes et pour rentrer dans sa
cellule
s'il ne nous dit mains pour voir et là
je me tourne vers selim à ce moment là
j'ai dit mais tu lui dis pas au revoir
c'est sans doute la dernière fois de ta
vie que tu loi et il a cette réponse
terrible mais justifiée il me répond
qu'il crève
moi j'avais perdu ma ceinture aux
portiques de sécurité parce qu'on doit
se dépouiller comme à l'aéroport
à ce moment là je panique chez ma
ceinture ma ceinture il dit qu'il se
pende avec ils comptent pas le revoir et
comparé prendre de ses nouvelles c'est
pour lui c'est vraiment un chapitre
tourner aujourd'hui ses limites une vie
mais une ville magnifique
en semaine tous parfois d'avoir des
petits tracas moi même j'ai un ami qui
s'est suicidée lui-même aurait pu passer
à l'acte il n'a pas fait s'est battu il
s'est construit aujourd'hui céline à une
vie magnifique il ya vraiment un message
d'espoir à travers sa reconstruction qui
est fabuleuse et oui c'est passé par la
vengeance mais elle a vraiment aidés
mais il y à un point que nous n'avons
pas mentionné parce qu'en fait
malheureusement on croit avoir évoqué le
pire on n'a pas évoqué le pire vous avez
appris un jour que vous aviez évidemment
quand j'étais tout petit servi d'appât
pour le rapt d'une des jeunes filles
c'est dur à vivre c'est on se sent
coupable
je sais que j'ai rien à voir là dedans
non mais bien sûr c'était dur me dire
c'est à cause de moi que cet été et pas
à cause de vous non c'est pas là vous
n'êtes pas responsables mais chokolo
vous êtes vous êtes victime s'est pas de
votre faute en fait c'est difficile à
entendre mais ce n'est pas de votre
faute
oui ça le sait le savoir elle acceptait
c'est différent c'est que j'avais quand
même un sentiment de culpabilité
c'est c'est moi qui était bébé c'est moi
qui ait servi d'appât c'est a été mise
en confiance par mois il faut savoir que
quand michel fourniret projette de
kidnapper marie ascension c'était après
la réception d'un mauvais bulletin de
notes de selim il lui arrache son bureau
il le charge dans un camion il est
gilles dudit état d'âme plus besoin tu
es un cancre je vais aller le vendre
c'est durant ce trajet là qu'il croise
marie ascension encore une fois si
céline qui endosse la responsabilité
dans cette histoire à tort évidemment
non c'est vraiment ils se posaient
souvent bien comme victime michel
fourniret c'est toujours la faute des
autres
il se plaignait de son sort oui je veux
dire souvent les pervers c'est jamais de
leur faute ils passent à travers les
gouttes et il accuse toujours il accable
toujours quelques uns de leurs maux
un jour ils étaient des 600 licenciés
d'une entreprise où il travaillait une
série et coordonner la maison il a dit
c'est pas grave façon et on me rappelait
ils ont besoin de moi et l'ont jamais
rappelé mais voici quelques lots dessus
tout il a besoin
il a besoin que les gens aient besoin de
lui il le suicide de sa fille
marie-hélène selon lui c'est la faute
des journalistes qui ont médiatisé la
faire il n'aurait pas dû selon lui si
nîmes
si on vous demande aujourd'hui est ce
que vous êtes nombreux
qu'est ce que vous répondez oui
absolument
j'ai refait ma vie mais dans son ouvrage
plein quant aux la question d'accord
pour vous quand j'étais petit mes
parents sont morts ces coucous petit
coucou à la conversation
bientôt ce sera le cas ce sera plus un
mensonge mais voilà c'est lille vous
même avez envie d'avoir des enfants
oui ce cas là vous me posez la même
question et de l'autre une famille
construit une famille nous avons envie
d'avoir des enfants
massa m'a dit un jour pour vivre heureux
vivons cachés tant que vous dites que
vous avez accepté on vous remercie
évidemment parce que c'est un témoignage
extrêmement puissant pour mettre de la
lumière sur des questions qui a été
occultée par les médias par les
enquêteurs quels sujets que celle de
vous je vous vois venir
mais l'accord dit quand même c'est ils
prenaient souvent quand on était à la
maison de la franc maçonnerie dans ses
lettres il faisait référence
et là il faisait référence à
un maître qu'il avait à des commandes
spéciales donc ceux qui restent supposer
que les mesures que nous vous avons reçu
en une lettre datée du du 5 janvier 2015
dans laquelle michel fourniret évoque un
homme qu'il appelle son maître
voilà c'est cette lettre qui passe la
main d'homme qu'il appelle son vénérable
maître paul louis deschamps qui le
côtoyaient à l'époque faut savoir que
selim assis sur un point c'est que son
père n'était absolument pas un loup
solitaire il avait beaucoup d'amis à
l'époque il y avait du passage à la
maison c'est ce qu'il répète sans cesse
dire qu'il ya des choses à découvrir
encore en fait ils évoquent un homme ce
que ce monsieur deschamps qui lui
faisait des commandes de machines
spéciales pour son laboratoire son
client et et et concurrent qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
est-ce que s'il s'agit d'un message codé
voilà nous on a été auditionné à
plusieurs reprises suite à notre visite
en prison on en a parlé aux enquêteurs
mais le problème est que cette personne
n'a jamais jamais été auditionnés et
nous avons d'ailleurs eu aucune suite à
ce que vaut une suite ils sont maîtres
on a saisi la police des polices
récemment parce que la police
actuellement j'ai récemment à lancer des
appels à témoins alors que nous
peut-être que cet homme c'est quelque
chose étant donné qu'il côtoyait fournir
et durant ces longues années d'impunité
un type quand même qui toujours
lendemain s'achète un château avec de
l'argent liquide
selim d'ailleurs m'a dit qu'ils allaient
beaucoup à bruxelles à l'époque pour
échanger laurent en argent liquide c'est
ça cet homme n'a jamais été entendu et
c'est vrai que ça c'est quelque chose
une zone d'ombré de ce que nous nous
avons trouvé durant notre enquête qui
nous laisse un peu coiron comprends pas
pourquoi cet homme n'a pas été
auditionné et selim indépendamment de ce
qui est encore un peu mystérieuse que
vous redoutez qui est la révélation
d'autres crimes commis non seulement par
votre père mais par vos par vos parents
c'est un jeu c'est qu'il y en a d'autres
bah je sais je suppose car il ya une
longue blanche de tommy et voilà il ya
les quelques 10 ans où il ne fait rien
et est ce que semble suggérer selim
c'est que fourniret est considéré comme
un prédateur uniquement isolé mais qu'il
est tout à fait possible que il est
parfois enlever aussi des petites filles
pour les livrer à d'autres personnes
ainsi de suite donc un fonctionnement en
réseau parce que
comme chacun sait on peut avoir un
cancer un bureau de tabac donc on peut
être à la fois soit mêmes prédateurs
soi-même consommateurs de ce qu'ils
appellent chair fraîche et aussi
malheureusement fournir des personnes
contre de l'argent
on a vu précédemment que fournirait
était intéressé puisqu'il n'a elle
n'hésite pas à tuer pour avoir le trésor
du gang des postiches
donc ça pose en fait le problème de tout
un système pédocriminels en réseau
auquel il serait étonnant qui n'est pas
d'une façon ou d'une autre adhérer un
peu à l'instar d'un dutroux d'ailleurs
un oui d'ailleurs il racontait qu'il
était pire que dutroux faut le savoir du
trou qui a récemment avoué que il se
plier à des commandes week est
maintenant est revenue dutroux avait
d'abord expliqué qu' il était un simple
prédateurs accompagné de sa femme et
d'un copain vaguement sdf
il a une vingt ans parce qu'on lui avait
expliqué que s'il disait la vérité
c'était le retour de la marche blanche
la belgique en colère tout le monde en
colère protégeons les enfants et
personne n'avait envie de ça d'ailleurs
j'ai juste une chose c'est l'hymne a été
auditionné récemment encore une fois par
la police
et d'après aux enquêteurs il y aurait
pas que le butin du gang des postiches
il avait encore plus d'argent que ça
avec moi j'ai rencontré andré bellaïche
l'ami de monsieur naulleau 4 entre
guillemets regeler questionné sur sur
son film d'ariel zeitoun avec vincent
elbaz il serait que le film se termine
on voit vincent elbaz qui je suppose et
de jouer son rôle parce que monsieur
bellaïche évidemment n'a jamais été
condamné pour ces faits et là c'est le
film se termine sur cette phrase quand
on est sorti voilà le butin avait
disparu y avait plus rien et moi j'étais
lui poser la question
promenez pas parler de fournir et est
rentré dans une colère terrible c'est ce
que je raconte dans le livre mais selon
lui avait pas de temps que ça d'argent
il y aurait une autre source
d'ailleurs c'est vrai que l'argent il
est très intéressé c'est comme ça qu'il
faisait chanter
selim en lui envoyant des mandats cash
en lui disant si tu continues à malmö
parler parce que c'est rick défend lui
rentrer dans le lard à très bien
connaître si tu continues à mal de
parler je t'envoie pas d'argent et donc
des fois c'est l'hymne leur envoyer ses
mandats cash déchiré en miettes une
histoire insensée en plus de l'aspect
qu'on connaissait tas de choses qui
sortent année après année
c'était un foudre de guerre vraiment si
moi je lui dis un moment donné en prison
jeudi mais vous vous rendez compte si
vous n'avez pas eu ce penchant pour les
petites filles
aujourd'hui vous seriez toujours dans
votre château de plusieurs hectares à
trôner à moulinsart qu il m'a dirigé
jamais vu une chose comme ça
moi j'ai juste hsa pour leur vendre
karim et ensuite j'ai eu une dernière
question pour moi c'est ce qui
m'interpelle un peu c'est votre travail
de reconstruction d'un monde dans notre
vie d'homme et à l'issue d'une question
à ce niveau là si vous me permettez
votre premier cercle de vie aujourd'hui
sait-il que vous êtes le fils de
fourniret houssin même avec ce premier
cercle
quelque chose que vous avez enfouis
effacés pour partir sur quelque chose
d'autre et esquisse qui m'interpelle
c'est même c'est même fascinant c'est de
lire peut-on vivre une vie en effaçant
une partie de sa vie quoi puis dire de
on y parvient à ça vous y arriver à ça
ou votre premier cercle est au courant
de qui vous êtes sur les offres de
grande partie de mes amis chers en
belgique
pierre réseaux sociaux et donc forcément
savent que je suis et mes amis proches
la jolie savent que je suis donc ça me
permet de faire un tri entre ce qu'ils
m'acceptent et ce qu'ils me considèrent
comme fils 2 et 1 mettra d'accord donc
mes amis je sais qu'ils sont
imax est que je suis donc ils savent et
surtout d'accord une dernière question
une pour céline slim et une pour holly
vous avez exprimé votre désaccord et
même votre opposition envers tf1 qu'il
voulait faire une fiction autour de
votre père tf1 a opposé une fin de
non-recevoir en disant qu'il veut la
chaîne ferait quand même cette fiction
pourquoi vous y être opposés je veux pas
qu'il soit vu comme un communiqué eaton
et même faire un film sur lui c'est
faire honneur mais sûrement déjà qu'ils
ne parlent pas pour faire exprès dans la
postérité
si on peut s'en faire un film sur lui
c'est la consécration pour le lycéen
ordinaire c'est un plus beau un cadeau
magnifique qu'on lui fait peur c'est le
mieux en plus c'est un tf1 a choisi un
roman c'est une fiction donc un bâtiment
aussi une fiction qui change les noms
qu'ils fassent pas michel fourniret et
monique olivier et moi j'aurais écrit
pour qu'il ne me suis pas dedans dans
cette histoire je suis pas contre l'idée
d'un
d'un film mais qui fasse un film positif
qu'il fasse un film sur la
reconstruction des gens sur la réponse
de tf1 cauet c'est une prison c'est
c'est liberté d'expression liberté
d'expression qui veulent mettre l'accent
sur la justice belge les enquêteurs qui
ont fait un excellent travail
la traque mais qu'elle traque
il a commis des attouchements en france
et était incarcéré en des années 80 et
en belgique
il a réussi à obtenir un poste de
surveillant de l'école puis un poste de
professeur sans casier judiciaire et
n'ont jamais pu donc qu'elle traque est
la bonne chose c'est que moi j'ai
rencontré le le beau père de céline qui
de l'ex mari de monique olivier qui
était supposée mourir sur ordre du
monique olivier sec tout à l'heure dans
le documentaire on attend de quelqu'un
peut amoindrir sa participation aux
faits en en croire qu'elle était presque
victime non le deal c'était de faire
abattre son premier mari moi j'ai
rencontré ce monsieur qui s'appelle
andré et pour lui il en est convaincu
lui-même andré taymans un ancien membre
de la dst
il a eu fournir et sur le dos à l'époque
qui voulait donc obéir monique olivier
parce que c'était le deal lui donner de
jeunes vierges et en contrepartie
voilà faire abattre mais ce monsieur à
battre pourquoi il va peut-être y avait
des choses pourquoi en dix ans elle
était battu mais c'est un accord mais
pas le cas moi j'ai rencontré ce
monsieur est ce qu'il m'a dit c'est que
lui il est convaincu il est vraiment
convaincu en tant que membres anciens
membres de la dst que fournirait était
un bar blues et que sa signature c'était
une balle derrière la tête il faut
savoir que monsieur monsieur quand il
revient vivre faire sa vie dans le sud
de la france avec ses lignes sous son
propre toit
il voit sa vie soudainement menacé du
jour au lendemain fourniret selon le ses
propres dires un jeu le site parce que
je les rencontre et auraient activé des
réseaux mafieux et politique ils
devaient se balader à cette époque avec
des poches trouées avec un calibre dans
le pantalon au cas où s'il devait
dégainer pour protéger sa vie et celle
de ses enfants
donc il ya encore énormément de zones
d'ombré dans la sphère fournir et de
tabous c'était c'était l'objet parce
qu'on va partir en publicité c'était
l'objet de ma dernière question est ce
qu'il ya des choses dont vous avez eu
connaissance soit en enquêtant soit vous
entretenant avec fourniret et que vous
n'avez pas mis dans le livre que vous
tenez cachez vous savez d'ailleurs moi à
la base j'avais signé
si vous en avez parlé des infos que vous
avez croisé promenade des anglais
j'avais d'abord signé avec une maison
d'édition belge si vous voulez je leur
envoie mon manuscrit au bout de 2 ans de
3 ans à l'écrire mon téléphone sonne et
là on m'explique que la lettre donc vous
avez diffusé tout à leur poste problème
est qu'il faut absolument la supprimer
cet homme qui m'appelle en plus son nom
n'apparaît nulle part dans
l'organigramme de la maison d'édition on
me somme de m'autocensurer alors que le
but moi de ma démarche était de donner
la parole au principal intéressé à
savoir michel fourniret donc je refuse
il attendait c'est un luxe quand même de
pouvoir tendre la paire tend le micro à
fournir et en personne je suis pas là
pour recopier des dépêches afp faire une
compilation de tout ce qu'on peut lire à
droite à gauche donc je refuse
et ce bras de fer il a duré un an on a
reçu beaucoup de pression par rapport à
ça donc il ya beaucoup de choses
évidemment qu'on a dû enlever comme
arthur aron dire certains angles et
andré videmment aussi pour des questions
de dreux 2 voilà des questions
juridiques pour pas être attaquées
derrière mais oui c'est d'ailleurs reçu
beaucoup de pression ça a été dur pour
céline d'ailleurs il n'a pas compris que
voilà à travers toute cette démarche qui
était supposée de positive on soit
attaqué ensuite de toutes parts et c'est
vrai qu'à un moment donné nous on a plus
compris qu'ils étaient les gentils qui
étaient les méchants parce qu'on s'est
fait pourrir même par la police